la polémica del día han sido las 560
operaciones realizadas por la policía
federal de las carreteras contra
autobuses que llevaban a electores es un
tema bastante complejo y para entenderlo
hay que explicar el contexto para evitar
la obsesión ayudar a los más pobres más
de 300 ciudades de Brasil han ofrecido
hoy transporte gratuito para cerca de 95
millones de brasileños y precisamente
para evitar obstáculos en este día el
presidente del tribunal superior
electoral había pedido a esta policía
federal de carreteras que no realizase
ningún Bleach ningún tipo de operación
en las carreteras para tener un tráfico
más ágil pero es sabido que los más
pobres suelen votar a Lula sobre todo en
el Noroeste y hay otro detalle antes de
la primera vuelta el actual presidente
acudió al tribunal superior electoral y
pidió que este transporte gratuito no
fuese concedido la máxima instancia
electoral negó esta Y es más la Corte
Suprema dio plenos poderes a los
ayuntamientos para ofrecer ese
transporte llegamos así al día de hoy
donde la Policía Federal de carreteras
de sóller la recomendación del tribunal
superior electoral y hace estas
operaciones además al mismo tiempo el
director de esta policía publica un
vídeo en sus redes sociales pidiendo el
voto por bolsonaro después lo apaga
mientras tantos o globo húndelo uno de
los principales diarios de Brasil
publica que este dispositivo habría sido
diseñado entre la policía y el gobierno
de bolsonaro en una reunión en Brasilia
el 19 de octubre hay un momento en que
parece que se puede extender el horario
electoral pero finalmente comparece
Alexandre dimorais presidente del
tribunal superior electoral y dice que
no que no vas a ampliar el horario
porque realmente no se impidió que los
votantes llegasen a los colegios y ahora
mismo en el colegio en el que está en el
centro de Río han cerrado las puertas y
solo permiten la salida de los últimos
electores
Valeria contanos cómo ha transcurrido Y
cómo está transcurriendo en general de
materia de seguridad de violencia no sé
si pudiste registrar o ver algún acto
algún tipo de hostilidad
Bueno yo puedo contar lo que ha pasado
aquí en este colegio que es el mismo en
donde estuvimos Hace cuatro años
cubriendo la primera vuelta nosotros
para estar aquí necesitamos una
autorización del tribunal superior
electoral de la delegación de Río de
Janeiro y concretamente del juez que
controla ese Distrito yo tenía el mail
de autorización y muchos electores
muchos de ellos con pegatinas de
bolsonaro vinieron a increparme y a
decirme que no podía estar aquí y
llamarron a los fiscales a cada uno de
ellos les tuve que enseñar el email que
yo había recibido y que estaba todo
siguiendo las reglas Pero bueno eso no
ha sido el único incidente del día
también ha habido momentos alegres hemos
visto como nunca personas votando con
las camisetas del flamengo para celebrar
la victoria ayer en la Libertadores
recordamos que el flamengo prometió al
tribunal superior electoral creía a
participar a posponer la celebración es
precisamente para evitar que hubiese
retraso hoy en la votación